i thank the almighty creator of heaven
earth and sea for the great mercy and
compassion which among the savage people
of the country brazil called the tupin
imba who ate men and whose prisoner i
was for nine months and amidst many
other dangers i am again safe in the
grand duchy of hess my much beloved
fatherland
[Music]
hans stardon from homburg in hesse
had resolved if it should so please god
to visit
india
i traveled to a city called seville
where i found three ships fitting out to
sail to a country called rio de plata in
america this region with the rich gold
country named pirao which was discovered
some years ago and brazil all form one
continent to conquer this land forthwith
several ships had been sent some years
before and one of them returning home
requested more assistance
saying how rich it was in gold
san vincente was an island which lies
close to the mainland the portuguese who
live therein have for allies a tribe of
brazilians who are called the toppin
ikin but this tribe had on both sides
enemies on the south side and also the
north side
having sent my slave the day before into
the wood to catch game i purposed going
the next day to fetch it so that we
might have something to eat
for in that country one has little else
beyond what comes from forests
now as i would this purpose walked
through the woods
there arose on both sides of the path
loud yells such as the savages are
accustomed to make and they came running
towards me i noticed them but found that
they had all surrounded me and leveling
their bows and arrows they shot in upon
me
i cried god help my soul i'd scarcely
finished saying these words when they
struck me to the ground and shot arrows
and stabbed at me so far they had not
thank god wounded me further than in one
leg and torn my clothes off my body two
of them raised me from the ground where
i lay naked one took me by one arm
another by the other and some went
behind me and others before
they ran in this manner quickly through
the wood towards the sea
i sighted their canoes from which they
had drawn up from the sea at the
distance of about a stone's throw or two
and also a great number more of them who
had remained with the canoes
when they ornamented with feathers
according to their custom saw me being
led along they ran towards me and
pretended to bite into their arms and
threatened as though they would eat me
before they launched the canoe they tied
my hands together and not being all from
the same dwelling place those of each
village were loathed to go home
empty-handed and disputed with those who
held me
some said that they had been just as
near me as the others and that they
would also have their share of me and
they wanted to kill me at once on that
very spot and so i stood and prayed
looking round for the blow
but at last their king who desired to
keep me began to speak and said they
would take me living homewoods
so that their wives might also see me
alive
and make their feast upon me
for they purposed killing me kawei
that is they would brew drinks and
assemble together to make a feast
and only then
they would eat me
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
question how many people lived in the
americas when columbus arrived in 1492.
a 3.2 million
b 15 million
c
60 million yes the answer according to a
recent study is 60 million although that
is hotly debated and just over a century
later had dropped to 5 million and so my
recommendation this week is one of
magellan's new documentaries which they
add every week rio the great saga is a
fascinating journey back in time to
explore the rich history of rio de
janeiro a crossroads of colonial history
and political and social revolutions an
amazing slice of brazil's rich history
and of course magellan have more than 3
000 other documentaries already on their
system to check out too and this
christmas voices of the past viewers can
take advantage of a special holiday
offer a buy one get one free gift card
for an annual membership by clicking on
the link in the description
thanks
[Music]
when we arrived close to their dwellings
these proved to be a village which had
seven huts and they called it uwatibi
[Music]
and close to it were their women in the
plantations of the route which they call
mandioca
in this set plantation walked many of
the women pulling up roots
to these i was made to call out in their
language a drunesque bean herme vrame
that is
i
your food
has come now when we landed all young
and old ran out of their huts which lay
on a hill to look at me the men with
their bows and arrows entered the huts
and left me in the custody of their
women who took me between them and went
along some before me and others behind
singing and dancing in unison with the
songs which they are accustomed to sing
to their own people when they are about
to eat them
now they brought me before the iwara
huts as i entered the women ran to me
and struck me with their fists and
pulled my beard and spoke in their
language with this blow i revenge my
friend him whom those among whom thou
has been has killed
thereupon they led me into the hutts
whilst the women came and struck and
pulled me before and behind and
threatened me how they would eat me all
the men were together in a hut and drank
the beverage which they called cowie and
had with them their gods called tamerka
and they sang in praise of them
this song i heard and i thought
now they prepare
to kill thee
after a little while those who had
captured me named yapipo wasu and his
brother al-kindar miri came to me and
told me how they had from friendship
presented me to their father's brother
iperu wazu who was to keep me and also
to kill me when i was to be eaten and
thus to gain a new name with me
further the two above mentioned who had
taken me said
now will the women lead the out to the
aprasi
this word i understood not then
but now i know it means dancing
then came all the women who were in the
seven huts and seized hold of me and the
men went away
several of the women led me along by the
arms and several by the ropes which were
bound around my neck so roughly and
tightly that i could hardly breathe and
i knew not what they intended to do with
me upon which i tried to remember the
sufferings of our lord jesus christ and
how he suffered innocently whereby i
consoled myself and became more resigned
i asked whether they were going to kill
me then when they answered
not yet
upon which a woman came out from the
crowd towards me holding a fragment of
crystal and with this same piece of
crystal shaved off my eyebrows i would
also have cut the beard from my chin but
this i would not suffer and said that
they should kill me with my beard
two women were with me and they tied to
one of my legs strings of objects which
rattled
thereupon the woman-kind all began
together to sing and to their time i was
obliged to stamp with their leg to which
they had tied the rattles so that they
rattled
in harmony
eventually i was handed over to
iperowasu who kept me in careful custody
he told me that i still had some time to
live and they brought all their gods
that were in the huts and placed them
around me and said that those had
prophesied that they would capture a
portuguese
then said i these things have no power
and also cannot speak and they lie in
asserting that i am portuguese for i am
one of the frenchman's allies and
friends and the country where i am at
home to which i belong is called germany
they knew full well that the frenchman
were just as much the enemies of the
portuguese as they for the frenchmen
came every year with ships and brought
them knives axes looking glasses combs
and scissors therefore they were good
friends which the portuguese had not
been they further said that the
portuguese had shot the father of the
two brothers who had captured me in such
manner that he died and that they would
now revenge their father's death
on me
thereupon i asked why would they revenge
upon me i was not portuguese
having come to understood that there
were french one among them and that
these were accustomed to arrive there in
ships i always persisted in the same
story and said that i belonged to the
allies of the french and that they were
to let me remain unkilled until sometime
as the frenchman came and recognized me
there was a frenchman living four miles
distant from the huts where i was
now when he heard the news he proceeded
thither then the savages came running
towards me and said
now a frenchman has arrived here we
shall soon see if you are a frenchman or
not of course i felt glad of that and i
thought at all events he is a christian
and he will say everything for the best
they took me into him naked as i was and
i saw that he was a young fellow he
addressed me
in french
and i of course understood him not the
savages stood round and listened
when i could not reply he said to the
savages in their language kill and eat
him
he is a true portuguese
my enemy and yours
this i understood well
i begged him therefore for god's sakes
that he would tell them not to eat me
and he said
they want to eat you
upon which i remembered the words of
jeremiah who says
cursed is he who putteth his trust
in man
[Music]
the above-mentioned frenchman remained
two days and on the third day he went on
his way
and they had agreed that they would
prepare everything and kill me on the
first day after they had collected all
things together
and they watched me very carefully and
both young and old mocked and derided me
now when i came close upon the huts i
heard a great noise of singing and
blowing of horns and in front of the
huts were fixed some fifteen heads on
stakes
these belonged to a tribe whom they
had eaten
as they led me past them they told me
they were the heads from the mark chaos
who were also their enemies
as we were entering the huts one of
these who had me in their keeping went
before me and spoke with loud words so
that the others heard it
here i bring the slave
the portuguese
he then led me to where the king sat and
drank together with the others and had
made themselves drunk with the beverage
that they make called kawawi the king
looked savagely at me and said
our enemy art thou come
then they gave me also to drink
at this point the king's son tied my
legs together in three places and i was
made to hop with joined feet through the
huts
at this they laughed and said
there comes our meat hopping along
upon this i asked my master whether he
had led me thither to be killed
he
said
no it was the custom that foreign slaves
were treated in this manner thereupon
they walked around me and grabbed at my
flesh one said the skin of the head
belonged to him and another that he
claimed the fleshy part of the leg
but my master always comforted me
saying that i was not to be killed
for the present
about eventide on the day when the
others again gone off and by moonlight
they assembled together on the open
space between the huts and debated among
one another when they would kill me
placing me also between them they
derided and threatened me
i was sad and looked at the moon and
thought to myself
my lord and my god assist me through
this peril to a peaceful end
then they asked me why i so constantly
looked at the moon
so i said to them
i see by her aspect
that she is angry
for the face which is in the moon
appeared even to me to be so terrible
that i thought to myself
god and all creatures must be angry with
me
but thereupon the king who was to have
me killed called japipuasu
asked me
with whom is the moon angry
so i said
she looks towards
thy huts
[Music]
after several days they all came home
together sick chipipo ordered me to be
led to the huts and told me how they had
been stricken with illness and that i
had well known it for he still
remembered that i had said the moon
looked angrily towards his huts
when i heard these words from him i
thought to myself
surely it must be through god's
providence that i last night as a four
said spoke about the moon
i was in great joy at this and i thought
today
god is with me
and so i told him that it was true
because he wanted to eat me though i was
not his enemy and therefore had
misfortune come upon him
upon which he said that nothing should
happen to me if it turned out that he
recovered
i knew not how best to pray to god and
thought if they regain health they will
yet kill me but if they die the others
will say let us kill him before more
misfortune happens on this account
so i submitted the matter to god
chipipo begged me hard that they might
again recover i walked round them and
laid my hands upon their heads as they
desired me to do
but god would not have it so
they began
to die
first died one of their children then
his mother died an old woman who was
baking the pots wherein were to be made
the beverages with which i was to be
eaten she also died after some days one
of his brothers died then another child
and another brother and so on now when
he saw that his children his mother and
his brothers were gone he feared much
that he and his wives would also die
he said that i was to tell my god to
withdraw his anger so that he might live
i of course comforted him and told him
there was no danger but that when he
recovered again he was not to think of
killing me
thereupon he answered
no and also commanded those in the huts
that nobody should injure me or threaten
to eat me
he nevertheless remained ill for a time
but he was at last restored to health
together with one of his wives who was
also ill
there died however about eight of his
friends besides others who had treated
me cruelly
now there were yet two other kings from
two other huts
one had dreamt that i appeared before
him and had told him that he was to die
i said no he was not to be afraid but
that he also was not to think of killing
me or advise others to do it
in like manner the other king had also
dreamt of me a dream which had terrified
him much and he called me to his hut and
then complained of it to me and said he
had once been to war and had captured a
portuguese and had killed him with his
own hands and had eaten of him so
plentifully that his chest or stomach
had ever since been delicate and he
declared that he would eat of no other
him also i paid to be of good cheer but
he was to take care never to eat human
flesh again
[Music]
thus they
left me alone for a while not knowing
quite what to make of me whether i was a
portuguese or a frenchman
they said i had a red beard like a
frenchman and though they had also seen
portuguese yet these had all black
beards
and so when the frenchman came again to
the huts he spoke to me in the savage
tongue and at that time i went about
unfettered then he asked me if i still
lived and i said yes i thanked god that
he had preserved me for so long and i
called him privately to a spot where the
savages could not hear what i said and
told him that he saw plainly that god
had preserved my life
but also that i was no portuguese
but a german and i asked if he had not a
christian heart in his bosom or had
thought that after this life there was
no other when he had strongly advised
that i should be killed
and so according to my request he told
the savages that he had not well
recognized me the first time but that i
was from germany and belonged to their
friends and that he wanted to take me
with him to where the ships generally
arrived
my masters
said no they would not give me up for
they had found me in the enemy's country
and i belonged
to them
it happened after several days that they
wanted to eat a prisoner in a village
nearby about six miles from where i lay
imprisoned
on the eve of this day when they
intended drinking to his death i went to
him and said to him
everything is prepared for thy death
he laughed and he said
yes
further i told him he was to be of good
cheer for they would only eat his flesh
but his soul would proceed to another
place without our countrymen's souls
also proceeded and where there was much
happiness
he then asked me if this was really true
i said yes
but
quoth he he'd never seen god
and i said
he would see him
in the next life
there was one more incident before i
escaped now among them was a slave
belonging to a tribe called the cario
who are also enemies of the savages that
are friends of the portuguese
so it happened about the year 1554
during the sixth month of my captivity
that the cario fell sick and his master
who owned him begged me to help him that
he might be well again and catch game
bringing something for us to eat but
that if i thought he would not recover
again he would give him to a good friend
who might kill him and gain a name by
him i tried but finally they said he
will die we will therefore before he
dies strike him dead i said no do not do
this he may perhaps recover
but it veiled not they dragged him
before the hutts and two of them held
him for he was so sick that he knew not
what they were going to do with him and
so came the one whom he had been given
to kill and struck him on the head so
that the brain sprang out
then they left him lying before the huts
and wished to eat him i told them not to
do this as he had been sick and they
might also fall ill therefore they knew
not what to do
but one of them came out the hut wherein
i was and called to the women to make a
fire near the dead man
and he cut his head off
then he cut him up and divided him
equally with the others as is their
custom and ate him all but the head and
bowels of which they had a loathing as
the man had been sick
i went now and again through the
different huts in one they broiled the
feet in another the hands and in the
third pieces of the trunk
then i told them how the carrier whom
they were broiling
and were going to eat had at all times
lied against me and had said that i had
shot several of their friends when i was
with the portuguese and in this he had
lied and he had never seen me
you know well i continued that he was
several years among you and never was
ill but now on account of the lies which
he told about me my god has become angry
and has stricken him with sickness and
has put into your minds that you should
kill him and eat him so will my god do
unto all wicked men who have worked me
harm
and who would further injure me
at such words
they were much terrified
it happened that one day some savages
came to me and said that they had heard
of firing which must be at itaron the
harbour also called rio de janeiro
hearing with certainty that a ship was
there i told them that they were to take
me to it as probably my brothers would
be there
eventually the news was brought to me by
the savages the two men from the ship
had arrived there i was overjoyed and
went to them and bade them welcome in
the savage tongue
when they saw me in such a wretched
plight they had pity upon me and divided
their garments with me
i asked them why they had come they
answered on my account as they had been
commanded to take me to the ship and to
affect this they were to use every means
and so i said to one of the two who knew
the language of the savages that he had
to feign the following he was to be my
brother and he was to make believe that
i would remain among them and collect
pepper and other produce until the ships
returned the next year about 10 sailors
who in some degree resembled me should
come together and state that they were
my brothers and wanted to carry me home
with them my false brothers should in no
way consent that i should again return
to the huts but declare that i should
return home for our father wished to see
me once again before he died
and so the captain told the savages that
he was the captain of the ship and was
desirous that i should go back to the
huts but that he was only one man and my
brothers were many he could not do
anything against them
these pretexts were all made in order to
part on good terms with the savages
and so the king went weeping about the
ship and said if they really wanted to
take me with them i was to return with
the first ship for he had considered me
now his son and was very angry with the
others for wanting to eat me
and one of his wives who was then with
him on board the ship had to cry over me
after their custom
and i also cried
according to their usage
[Music]
and so in such manner did the almighty
god the god of abraham isaac and jacob
help me out of the hands of the tyrants
to him be praise honor and glory through
jesus christ his dear son
our savior
amen
[Music]
you